erika buen día y usted está siguiendo la
audiencia de hoy que nos puede contar de
lo que ya se escucha
hola ángel así es la audiencia número 14
de este proceso que debe durar
recordemos los dos meses la de hoy está
dedicada justamente como tú decías a
analizar los hechos que ocurrieron en
esa toma de rehenes del supermercado
judío de la puerta de avance en donde
murieron cuatro personas y 26 estuvieron
encerradas durante cuatro horas con
ahmed y cool y bali el terrorista y ha
sido una audiencia dura porque hemos
podido ver las imágenes de las cámaras
de vigilancia cuando a me disculpa él y
se mueve en el supermercado y abate a
las cuatro personas que fallecieron
hemos podido ver también el cuerpo del
terrorista e incluso su arsenal y las
autoridades se preguntan por qué él
estaba tan armado todas las armas que
tenía estaban multiplicadas por tres
parecía que quería atacar junto a la
ayuda de unos cómplices y también
podemos ver imágenes pero no verlas sino
que escucharlas las que él tomó con la
cámara gopro que llevaba porque él grabó
todo el asalto y llama la atención que
las víctimas hablaban con las personas
que estaban encerradas en los
supermercados intentaban como hacerse
sus amigos y él les explicaba intentaba
justificar los hechos que estaba
realizando les decía es culpa vuestra
porque ustedes eligen un presidente
en impuestos a un gobierno que mata
mujeres y niños en otros países
erika esta tarde la alcaldesa de parís
va a dar testimonio pero no todos están
de acuerdo con esto cuéntenos más
efectivamente sobre todo la defensa de
los 11 acusados presentes recordemos que
son en total 14 acusados 11 están
presentes porque ellos dicen porque
viene ella es una tribuna política a la
que le están dando si se trata de juzgar
a las autoridades y la responsabilidad
que pueden tener en estos ataques porque
por ejemplo no pudieron prevenirse este
tipo de ataques terroristas que inviten
al presidente françois hollande a que
prohibió por ejemplo que se instalará un
vehículo policial durante 24 horas al
día en las afueras de cali ebro así que
vamos a ver lo que pasa pero el juez se
defiende él dice yo tengo el derecho de
invitar a quien quiera a esta audiencia
y considero que es necesario que la
alcaldesa de parís venga también a
testimoniar